how's it going bros mining this Pam bad
I can do facade with little knives a lot
of me isn't gonna background or have a
trap
and that's grave and I'm gonna be honest
I am I am gonna be honest they didn't
[ __ ] crazy okay
let's start off put on some data for you
bros all right what are we gonna be I
want to be gone Silas again but I had
atom that year maybe Heather Jared just
yeah Jim Joe John Julie Keith penis car
car guys coming for a visit
ha all right God My Name Is Khan and I'm
here to solve this in a relationship
problem that you have okay here we go
back I'm here open for [ __ ] sake guys
yes yes so happy you could make yes you
better be good
yes I'm not why does he keep saying no
no here we I don't even know God hi how
are you oh god it's been such a long
time
yes your breasts are bigger
okay whatever cellphone this is mine
kind of a bold way to say hello yes that
a problem
okay so please make yourself a thesis
crisis ugly I get it out of my face okay
so nice to be pixie bra
where's my phone oh nice my I told you
it's mine
why do I put this stupid phone no I get
that in my face from my business contact
damn it you know I can't
this is Cod [ __ ] game no please don't
do that what do you want
Oh dad I can hear his voice a sound that
right diet oh good you hung up I can
call him back later or in a few days so
well I'm the selecting a pair there we
go that's what I'm talking about fancy
new cocktail shakers I'm itching to try
out fancy what are you a [ __ ] Oh
drinks so what's your poison how about a
martini how about a penis
i I was joking
now make me some scotch
you had me going there for a sec scotch
come on spot there you go
I hug you now where's my scotch yes
great I have to do everything on my own
I'm just gonna make you a martini
why is alcohol something fell for me
maybe you'd like some juice or mineral
water
God wants to get drunk
but this this give me something okay
okay this never never
why know what I'll be right back Greece
what
no you two keep talking about the bar
and drinks in the amazing what woods
what's the problem bro bro bro bro bro
let me tell you something yeah bro bro
bro come here bro come here um grace my
love could you no no no no no no it's
not I'm gonna prosciutto you know that I
served at our last prom bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro bro yo Garf Garf
friendly real it's a real [ __ ] mister
it hurts to know what but it's the turf
and as a bro maybe she heard me see you
leave her in the kitchen and that
happens what do you expect women women I
told you she's a real
hey say come lass
err woman what so annoying
I'm trying not to get kicked out this
car yes bro you think you can make it
bro bro it's gonna be great
bro I don't have time for parties come
on come on come on take a joke
wait what is it taking me I can't even
take a stupid joke
stupid couple I hate them all right I
think that was the last longest time
I've lesson that's what she said anyway
I guess that's pretty much it I will see
if I do more of these I'm not sure it's
getting kind of repetitive but anyway
that's it like and favorite
I just left your stuff what are you I'm
late alright why is he going oh yeah I
want to go back what to get throw in to
throw me out